welcome everyone to the advanced science
at virtual oncology conference this is
the biomarker discovery track
my name is alessandra cesano and i have
the privilege
of moderating today's session which
include
five exciting talks focusing on novel
approaches
biomarker discovery in the field of
tumor earth
interaction before starting
i have few housekeepers note for a
complete
biography on today's speaker please
visit the tab at the top of your screen
and also if you have any question we
encourage you
to submit them in a q a box
our speaker will respond back to you via
email
before starting with the presentation i
just have two slides to briefly frame
the context of today's presentation
the tumor microenvironment is a
multifaceted ecosystem
characterized by profound cellular
heterogeneity
dynamicity plasticity in the series of
complex
intracellular crosstalks schematically
we can recognize different
layers of heterogeneity in the tumor
microenvironment
a layer that include as a first one the
cancer
cell genetic feature oncogenic pathway
driving mutation a second layer that
include non-malignant cells
like the new cells or the fibroblasts in
a third layer
that involve cross cellular crosstalk
which is affected by a stress and
secreted
molecule as well as carried antigens
and receptor diversity
the striking responses obtained with
immune checkpoint blockade
for instance at demonstrating the
enormous potential
of anti-cancer treatment that target the
tumor microenvironment components
instead of tumor cells therefore
how holistic multiplex and multiomi
an integrated approach in the
investigation
of the different facets of the tumor
microenvironment is needed
master is modulation and achieve
an effective control of human growth so
how we can do that
well this slide summarizes the main
approaches for multiomic profiling
of the tumor microenvironment by
schematically dividing them based on the
level of resolution particularly for
tumor sample resolution
cellular single cell resolution or
spatial resolution
each level of resolution has different
characteristics which can be used to
optimally address specific biologicals
the bulk profiling the full tumor sample
profiling
is the most standardized widely used
and provides high throughput
representation of molecular features of
the tumor microenvironment as all
it has been and still is the main
horsepower in the host tumor interaction
profiling and these are the basis of
some of the main
discoveries in the biomarkers in like
the average representation that is
provided by the bulk approach
emerging single cell technology allow
for the generation of ohmic profiling
at the level of the single cells this
allows for the dissection
of the intra-tumor heterogeneity and
then to shed slide on ref
cells that can play a role in cancer
progression or specific cell subsets for
instance like
new cell subside however currently the
cost and the technical complexity
particularly on the side of the
computational side of things
limit the throughput in terms of both
the number of features
that can be examined as well as the
number of
cells that can be assayed at a single
time
finally another emerging technology are
the
imaging technology that allowed for
ohmic dataset to be generated from tumor
tissues
slides that retain the information
related to the spatial resolution
thus providing an additional layer of
information
for a better understanding of the tissue
biology
and on this latter approach we will hear
from many of our speakers today
so with this short introduction now
let's move to our first talk
it is my pleasure to introduce you to dr
audrey thompson professor of cancer
biology
co-director of the breast cancer
translational genomics initiative
mayo clinic comprehensive cancer center
at jacksonville
florida the title of this talk is
spatially resolved evaluation of triple
negative breast cancer
expand knowledge of immune cell tumor
cell interaction
please join me in welcoming dr thompson
i will know i will now turn the
presentation over
good afternoon it's a pleasure to be
with you this afternoon to be able to
share with you
some highlights of the work that we've
been doing using the nanostring geomics
digital spatial profiling instrument to
begin to map
the immune landscape of triple negative
breast cancer
before i begin i have to emphasize one
thing this is very much a collaborative
project and everyone listed here
has been a significant contributor to
this project but a couple of people
really deserve special mention jennifer
concergus in my laboratory
is probably run more dsp samples than
anyone outside of mayo clinic
and she's excuse me outside of
ministering and
she has really been the workhorse in all
the data that i'm going to show you
in addition i need to cite doug
heyerfeld doug was in has been involved
in these
experiments from the very beginning was
involved in experimental design
in data collection data interpretation
and he has been a stalwart contributor
throughout all of these studies
so what i'm going to talk to you a
little bit about today initially
is some studies that we've done with the
set of triple negative breast cancer
that came from the phenix x adjuvant
trial of
fluoropyrimidines we've done a number of
things with these studies but what i'm
going to talk to you today
is about data that we've obtained using
a beta version of the
other geomixed dsp platform to begin at
the immune landscape of
these samples so from the phenoxx trial
we selected two cohorts of 22 patients
each
one of these cohorts had a median
recurrence
of 2.3 years the other had
a minimum of nine years
follow-up recurrence-free survival with
10.7 years media and recurrence-free
survival so we're comparing two groups
of tumors
one of which recurred and one of which
did not recur
and these tumors are otherwise balanced
with respect to
their clinical and pathological features
we stain these tumors these slides with
a
cocktail of antibodies that contain the
oligonucleotide targeted antibodies
against 42
target
reagents that was available to us in
addition use fluoroforce stained
fluorophore tagged antibodies against
cd45
cd68 and pan cytokeratin as
morphological markers so what we see
when we stain the tumors is shown here
pancetta keratin stains the tumor cells
tells us where the tumor cells are and
it's shown up here in green
cyto13 is a nuclear diet so we use it to
identify
the cells that are within the stroma
we've stained the tumors with cd68 so we
can identify regions that were enriched
for macrophages
and for cent with cd45 to identify
regions that are enriched for
leukocytes within these tumors then we
select a 300 micron region of interest
in this case
the interface between the green
cytokeratin positive tumor
and the um the stroma the strong in this
case is defined by the presence of
nuclei so the stronger really here
the important part of the stronghold
here is that it's blue not that it's red
appears that it's the red that we're
selecting but in fact it's the blue
so we segment these we segment them each
each of these regions of interest
into two regions the panasonic keratin
positive
tumor region and the cyto 13 nuclear
stain
cytokeratin negative stromal regions
we selected three different kinds of
rois from these tumors we selected rois
that contain
little or no tumor tumor enriched rois
we selected rois that were enriched for
cd45
and we selected regions of interest that
were enriched for cd68
and all three of these regions of
interest were then segmented
into for example cd45 enriched tumor
cd45 enriched stroma more specifically
cd68 enriched stroma and tumor that's
adjacent to cd68 enriched tumor
we collected these segments and then
analyzed the number of antibody
molecules that were bound to each of
these discrete segments
the data are sort of summarized here
this is probably impossible to really
make much sense out of
but the thing that i'll call your
attention to is the red the red
indicates significant overexpression
in patients that did not recur
and i think that what you can see here
rather easily
is that there's a lot going on in the
tumor the tumor is the the
in the the tumor segments of the cd45
tumor
cd68 tumor and the tumor without
adjacent stroma
have a large number of proteins that are
differentially expressed
whereas in the stroma it's really rather
quiet the only things that show up are
in all of the segments are gcmb and
pdl2 so there's something going on in
the stroma i mean
the tumor excuse me there's there's
information in the tumor that is not
recapitulated in the stroma and for
example i'll show you here cd56
the nk cell marker cd56 in tumor
segments is associated with durable
recurrence-free survival
in this case in cd60a in tumor that's
adjacent to cd68
enrichment so it's significant cd56 is a
significant prognostic indicator
in the tumor segments but is not a
significant prognostic indicator
in the adjacent stromal segments so
there's a lot of information that we're
getting from the tumor
that we're not getting from the strong
we're going to focus in the rest of this
talk actually
on three particular proteins two antigen
presenting cell
protein cd40 and hladr and then the nk
cell marker cd56 as you can see in the
table
all three of these are significantly
associated with
outcome in the tumor segments
but none of them are significantly
associated with outcome
in the stronghold signal so this is
again consistent with the idea
that there's information that we're
getting in the tumor
that's not being obtained if we simply
look at the stromal segments
now the issue that comes up when you
look at these data as well
t4dc56c hlidr
those are are fairly well known um
lymphoid cell markers what's the chance
that when we see these things that are
associated with outcome that we're just
having we're just it's a surrogate view
of tumor infiltrating lymphocytes or
tills so is there really more
information here
than we would get if we had simply
measured tumor infiltrating lymphocytes
well we don't have classical h e stained
tumor infiltrating lymphocyte data from
the fenextrial
but what we do have is very high
resolution digital images from tumors
that are stained with cd45 and cd68
and my colleague jody carter
developed a series of analyses using
halo
instrumentation to measure the number of
cd45
positive cd68 minus cells
to measure the density of these in each
of the tumors so this is essentially
digital tills analysis so we look at
that
we see initially that tumor infiltrating
lymphocytes are in fact prognostic and
triple negative breast cancer they
should be that's been known for a long
time
another question becomes is there
anything other than this going
on and in fact what we see
is that tumor infiltrating lymphocytes
can convey a certain amount of
information
but not the whole story so what i've
presented here
is cd45 positive cells plotted against
the concentration of
hladr each of those dots represents a
single tumor
the red dots represent tumors that
recurred
the green dots represent tumors that did
not
occur okay now if you look
at the lower left hand corner of that
slide what you'll see
is that tumors that have very low level
of
cd45 positive cells and low levels of
hladr
that those patients do very well don't
say those are mostly red those patients
recur okay but if you look
above that if you look at the low till
high
hladr what you'll see is that there is a
population of cell
tumors excuse me that have low level
of tumor infiltrating lymphocytes but
have in fact high levels of tills
of high levels of hladr
and those patients do perfectly well
okay so in general when we look at these
data what we tend to see
is that hladr in the tumor segments
is a more robust prognostic indicator
than total tumor infiltrating
lymphocytes
we looked at this in somewhat more
detail in three dimensions here
using cd40 hladr and cd56
to distribute the tumors again each dot
is a single tumor
green is no recurrence red is
recurrence these are stromal segments
so we've looked at the expression of
these three markers in stromal segments
and as you can see
there's a considerable amount of
heterogeneity within the stroma
but for the most part the tumor samples
that recur
pretty much overlap with the tumor
samples that do not recur
we see a very different situation when
we look in the tumor segments themselves
what we see here is that the tumors that
recur
the red dots here cluster very tightly
with low level abundance of cd40 hladr
and cd56 so the tumors that recur
are uniformly cold for these three
markers
in the tumor segments conversely
the tumors that did not recur exhibit a
great deal of heterogeneity so they're
fairly well spread out
based on these three individual markers
and and distribute very differently
from the tumors that recur
if we look at this in two dimensions we
see something even more striking
in this case i've plotted hladr
expression
against cd56 expression and what you can
see
is that hladr and cd56 are basically
expressed in different subsets of tumors
so tumors that have high level hladr
tend to have very low levels cd56
tumors that have high levels dd56 tend
to have very low level hla dr
so what we're really looking at here is
three different immune landscapes
we've got an immune landscape that that
contains very low level
cd56 and very low level hladr
and by and large those patients don't do
very well at all
we have an additional immune landscape
that contains high-level cd56 and
low-level hladr
those tumors those individual tumors
tend not to recur likewise tumors that
have high-level hla dr
and low-level cd56 10 to recur
so to summarize what i've shown you up
to this point
uh i i think that our data strongly
indicate that the immune cells that are
in intimate contact with the tumor cells
may in fact be more informative than
just looking at total mercedes and
stromal
tumor infiltrated lymphocytes i think
that our data indicates that tumors that
have
high level expression of natural killer
cell markers
are androgen presenting cell markers
have better prognosis
and that seems to be um irrespective of
the presence
or our relative
lack of tumor infiltrating lymphocytes
in those tumors
so we're seeing something that's really
quite different from what we see if we
simply measure stromal
tumor infiltrate lymphocytes and then
finally as i emphasized previously
we're looking at three potentially
distinct immune landscapes
identified by the markers that i've
shown you here
so we have a cold immune landscape those
bases tend to do poorly
we have a cd56 or natural killer cell
enriched
presumed to be a natural killer cell
enriched
landscape and those patients do well and
then we have an
additional immune landscape that's
characterized by high
hladr i can show you the same thing with
cd40 they're both markers for antigen
presenting cells
and tumors that have high level
expression of either or both of those
apc cell markers tend not to recur
so there's multiple immune landscapes
that are
detectable within tumor segments that
are associated with
favorable prognosis in triple negative
breast cancer
none of those are detectable within the
strong signals
i'd like to finish this afternoon by
telling you some
data from a preliminary analysis of a
triple negative breast cancer tissue
microarray this microarray contains 287
patients
and was constructed by the mayo clinic
breast cancer spore and we obtained it
through the good offices of matt getz
this tissue microarray is really quite
different from the fenex samples that
we've been discussing
so the phenx samples were selected for
early stage tumors whereas the tissue
microarray was
essentially drawn from all mayo clinic
triple negative breast cancer patients
so there's no selection for tumor stage
or grade in fact there's no selection
for therapy among these
patients as opposed to the fenex extract
in which all the patients were treated
with the same therapy
so this is a tissue microarray it was
constructed to have two cores from each
tumor
so we've got a maximum of four segments
from each tumor too from each core as
opposed to 24 segments
that we had with the fenex tumor so
there's there's considerably more
um statistical assurance in the
quality of the data from the triple
negative breast cancer
from the from the fenex x trial than it
is from the the
tma
the cores were selected for the tma by a
pathologist who simply went in and
selected for course that had high tumor
density
so this is really quite different from
the selection process that was used from
the fenex trial and these cores are
actually
fairly similar to the tumor without
adjacent
stroma regents of interest that we
selected from fedex x
and then finally the thenxx analyses
were done on
a beta version of the genomics of the
geoex dsp
machine using beta reagents
the tma was analyzed on the commercial
version of the machine using commercial
reagents which involves some
subtle changes in the antibodies that
were used to measure these proteins
so what i'm really telling you is that
there's almost nothing in common between
the fenix egg samples and the tissue
microarray samples other than the fact
that they're both
negative so it's really rather
surprising when you look at the data
this is a plot of
the 39 proteins that were common
to eat to both the phenix x and the
tissue microarray analysis
each spot there each dark spot black
spot
is a single protein and you can see that
there's actually a remarkable
correlation
between the normalized counts for every
protein
in the fenex samples
dsp technology the ability to compare
two different two very very different
sets of tumors
um at the level of normalized uh permian
expression
and get this kind of correlation is is
almost breathtaking
at any rate we went on and we carried
out a series of experiments we measured
the intensity we measured the abundance
of
the the proteins uh using dsp technology
and as you can see here that we got for
the tumors that recurred
in the tissue microarray were very
similar to those that we observed with
the connects x
the tumors that recurred cluster very
tightly with respect to these three
markers these tumors are cold whereas we
look at the tumors that did not recur we
see
essentially the same thing we see a
great deal of heterogeneity
within the tumors that did not recur
and that heterogeneity again reflected
by differences in the expression of
these three markers cda
cd40 hladr and cd56
when we look at this again in two
dimensions you see it's something that's
really quite similar to what we saw
with the finnex x data we're seeing
three different
or a minimum of three different immune
landscapes there's a high hladr
landscape a high cd56 landscape and then
a cold landscape
and those landscapes really differ with
respect to their
prognostic significance the cold tumors
tend to occur
whereas the hladr or low feed cd56 do
not
and the high cd56 likewise
tend to have better prognosis so
to wrap this up a few things i think uh
warrant being said by way of conclusion
i think that the data show you
um in this brief presentation and again
i emphasize that what i've shown you are
mostly highlights
from these studies but i think that what
the data indicate
is that the genomics dsp platform is
really providing a powerful new way for
us to begin to look at the immune
landscape
of breast cancers like not only breast
cancers but other sorts of tumors as
well
i think the most interesting thing that
we're that we're beginning to see
is that there is information within the
tumor compartment
that's going to give us new insight into
immune features that are associated with
therapeutic outcome and breast cancer
i think that we're seeing that there are
multiple immune landscapes i've i've
shown you i believe evidence
for three immune landscapes but
undoubtedly there are other types of
immune landscapes within
the triple negative breast cancer these
immune landscapes appear to be
mutually exclusive that is there are
some tumors
that have high cd56 and they do very
well
there are other tumors that have high
hladr and they also do well
but those are not the same tumors
different immune
landscapes associated with algae and
then finally i think that they overall
indicate the fact that
analysis of protein abundance in a
spatially defined
manner is going to really add a whole
new dimension to vital marker discovery
and to enable us to begin to ask
fundamental questions about the immuno
immunobiology
of breast cancer and the relationship
between immunobiology and therapeutic
outcome
in this case in terms of chemotherapy
but also in terms of immunotherapy as
well
so i'll finish up by expressing my
thanks to the patients who contributed
their samples
to the fennec sex trial to haiki johnshu
who was the
principal investigator on that trial
without him we obviously could not have
gotten any samples torsten nielsen the
university of british columbia
actually initiated these studies which
were funded in part by the national
cancer institute
the breast cancer research foundation
and donna deegan
and then finally i need to express my
profound thanks i noticed ring not only
um doug henerfield and sarah warren and
duran brower who were involved in
experimental design and interpretation
but
specifically to the outstanding genomic
support that even held our hands
through all of these now
um almost 600 tumors that we've analyzed
to date
so i'll stop at that point thank you for
your attention and i'll attempt to
answer any questions that you may have
thank you dr thompson for a very
informative presentation
i have a few questions for you your data
seem to imply
the stromal tumor infiltrating
lymphocytes
may be relatively important
to the outcome of triple negative breast
cancer do you agree with this
interpretation of your data
uh no i i don't agree with that at all i
i did not mean to give you that
impression certainly
we know that stromal tumor infiltrating
lymphocytes are our
prognostic significance in triple
negative breast cancer
and there's a lot of discussion about
whether or not evaluation of stromal
till
should become part of routine clinical
practice so i think that that's a
that's been a very useful way to look
at the immunobiology of triple negative
breast cancer
but i think the reality of it is that
there's a great deal more information
that we can have um above and beyond
just simply looking at stromal tills
we've looked at stromal tumor
infiltrating lymphocytes because that's
what we could do
because we could stain the stroma we
could count the lymphocytes it's very
difficult to count lymphocytes and tumor
by conventional h d it's very difficult
to count macrophages
but the the dsp technology now gives us
the ability to look
at protein markers that are associated
with natural killer cells or
with apc cells
or macrophages and to look at that
within both the stroma
and the tumor so no i'm not saying that
strongholds are not important they
certainly
are important i'm just saying that the
immune cells that
ultimately i think are going to be more
important are the immune cells that are
within the tumor
it's the immune cells that are actively
engaged with the tumor cells
rather than the immune cells that are
out in the stroma
kind of wondering what they're supposed
to do next
thank you along the same lines do you
have any
insights into the mechanism that
underline the difference
with respect to heterogeneity that you
observe in tumor semen
from patients who occur in those who do
not
that that that's almost a version of the
question that i
just answered um we do not at this time
understand why some tumors have high
levels of cd56
other tumors have high levels so hladr
or cd40
obviously that's a very important
fundamental biology question
but we have not yet been able to
tease out the answer
thank you very much interestingly
your date identify a subpopulation of
tumors that are immunologically cold
but did not occur if you look at this
cold tumor to see if there are any other
immunological features
that might be pronounced
so the question of validation uh comes
up when you're looking
at any new technology of this sort um
one attempt that we've made at
validation obviously is to do
immunohistochemistry using antibodies
against
some of these markers
the problem that we've run into in
trying to do that is that
immunohistochemistry is actually
relatively insensitive and many of these
markers that we're looking at
are not high abundance markers dsp is
exquisitely sensitive and so we can see
we can measure things we can quantify
things
and quantify changes in immune proteins
using dsp at a level that's far far
below the lower limits of detection of
immunohistochemistry
so that that method of validation is has
not been successful for us
thus far i will say the following thing
i think that the data that i
presented um in comparing the
fenex tumors to the tissue microarray
tumors
does speak at to one level of validation
the observation that with those two
radically different
tumor subsets that when we look at
the abundance of
a large number of individual proteins in
those two subsets that show that they
correlate very highly
from one to the other i think that that
does speak to the robustness of
technology it doesn't necessarily mean
that the technology is accurate but it
does mean that it's reproducible
so i think that that at this point um
validation is a is a question that that
we're all concerned with
and um we and a number of other
laboratories are
are working on that at this time
thank you very much finally have you
attempted to validate
any of your observations using
orthogonal technologies
um not yet i you know obviously there is
a population
of triple negative breast cancer
patients whose tumors are cold
most of those tumors recur but some of
those cold tumors do not recur it so
presumably there are
features that we can discern within that
subpopulation of
cold tumors that um do not recur
presumably that's
that may be another immune landscape
alternatively it may have nothing
whatsoever to do with the immune system
but
um we're we're we're obviously aware of
that potential question
and it's a subject of ongoing
investigation
so in summary i think that we're
entering
a new field the field of spatial biology
and that we can look
forward to fundamental
new observations on the nature of breast
cancer
the way that breast tumor cells interact
with immune cells
and the consequences of those
interactions
with respect to
therapy ultimately i think contributing
to
the overall goal that we're all working
for and that is to reduce
breast cancer mortality thank you for
your attention
thank you again dr thompson for your
presentation and discussion